welcome back to Las Vegas now the aid
and Night Market is coming back to Las
Vegas on October 8th celebrating our
local Asian and Pacific Islander
business Community as a community right
Chloe shot with age with the Asian
Community developmental Council and
Melissa Volo of 702 macarons I'll
explain that in a minute are here to
tell us more first and foremost macarons
versus macaroons explain it Melissa
so
um macarons are the French pastry or
cookie that's made with almond flour
rice sugar and egg whites and they have
a filling in the middle and you sandwich
them together okay and so they are soft
and chewy with a little bit of crisp
okay so we are learning so much today
and now let's talk to you Chloe about
the night market and just what it is why
you guys are bringing it to the commute
or bringing it back to the community
right so the last time we held the event
was in 2019. we were just so excited to
come back after the pandemic this is a
really wonderful time to bring the
community together for Asian and Pacific
Islander businesses we have wonderful
restaurants and Merchants I'm selling
Wares we have over 50 vendors coming out
and we're just really excited to be
there um on October 8th at CSN
Charleston there you go in one of those
50 vendors is 702 macaron so let's talk
about you know your product and and
where we can find you besides the night
market where you located uh we're
located in Henderson we have a bakery
where we specialize in custom order
macarons we do it for any kind of event
or catering and then we also have a
walking bakery that you can come in and
put your own box together we have a
variety of flavors on hand usually about
at least 20 when you walk in so there's
a lot to choose from and a lot of great
flavors oh my gosh well while I taste
them I'm gonna pick one this is they're
all so attractive I just want them all
but while I while I go ahead and taste
can you just tell us about the other
vendors that we can see just give
everybody a little preview absolutely so
we have a lot of different wonderful
vendors coming out that night we have
chill house we have of course
international marketplace we have
neighbors we also have giusando of
course specializing in the wonderful
Japanese katsu sandwiches we also have I
love cotton candy just a lot of
different really wonderful offerings for
that night and something for everybody
little dings is actually coming out for
the first time specializing in Taiwanese
braised pork over rice so we're really
excited for that wow okay while you were
explaining that I was over here this is
so good what flavors can I just guess is
it Rose it's Rose lychee oh my oh my God
so good this is amazing okay in October
8th where can people get tickets
absolutely Asian night market lv.com and
you can buy tickets online thank you
ladies thank you so much for having us
again Asian Night Market is happening
October 8th at the CSN Charleston campus
from six to midnight so you can get your
tickets at Asian nightmarketlv.com and
these macarons are delicious